[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Gabrielle Atal ministre de l'éducation
nationale depuis votre prise de fonction
en juillet dernier vous avez fait de la
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire une
des priorités de votre action en tant
que ministre de l'éducation ainsi votre
engagement total a permis la libération
de témoignages ces témoignages nous les
avons parfois retrouvés parfois
découvert et oui il faut témoigner
témoigner des dé tourments incessants de
leur prolongement également dans
l'espace numérique témoigner pour mieux
dire stop stop au harcèlement témoigner
parce qu'on est victime témoigner parce
qu'on l'a été même des années après
témoigner pourquoi pas aussi parce qu'on
a harcelé parfois sans le vouloir
parfois sans le savoir témoigner aussi
parce que l'on est témoins on est tous
témoins du harcèlement d'autres
personnes sur d'autres personnes
détecter la situation pour mieux la
régler c'est aussi ça la vigilance
partagée le incernement n'implique pas
seulement une relation entre un auteur
et une victime l' réduire ce serait
encore plus isolé or nom d'orénavant
personne ne doit être seu face au
harcèlement le harcèlement implique
toute la communauté communauté éducative
communauté nationale aussi et c'est
toute notre communauté que vous avez
invité à se mobiliser ce jeudi 9
novembre dans 2 jours c'est la Journée
nationale de lutte contre le harcèlement
dans tous les établissements scolaires
de France vous aviez évoqué des heures
banalisées pour permettre à toutes et à
tous d'échanger vous aviez également
parlé d'un questionnaire
d'autoévaluation pour mieux détecter ces
situations à l'école pouvez vous nous
les préciser nous préciser comment va se
dérouler cette journée et au-delà même
de cette journée jeudi et parce que je
connais votre attachement à cultiver
l'empathie que prévoyez-vous en ce sens
auprès des élèves de leurs enseignants
mais également auprès des parents je
vous remercie merci beaucoup ma cher
collègu la parole est à Monsieur Gabriel
Atal ministre de l'éducation nationale
et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Céline Calvez vous l'avez dit
cette semaine est une semaine décisive
dans le combat que nous menons contre le
harcèlement sous l'autorité de la
première ministre et qui s'est
concrétisé par le plan que la première
ministre a présenté il y a plusieurs
semaines chaque année il y a une journée
nationale de lutte contre le harcèlement
en général elle réunit autour d'un tiers
des établissements qui organisent des
actions autour du harcèlement cette
année nous avons voulu que cette journée
soit inédite par son ampleur très
concrète à partir de jeudi prochain les
cours s'arrêteront pendant 2hur dans
toutes les classes de France pour avoir
un temps dédié à la lutte contre le
harcèlement très concrètement les
équipes éducatives avec les élèves
échangeront sur le phénomène du
harcèlement très concrètement aussi sera
proposé à tous les élèves un outil
d'auto-évaluation du harcèlement cet
outil ce questionnaire on l' construit
avec des spécialistes de la santé
mentale de l'enfant de l'adolescent des
spécialistes du climat scolaire je pense
au professeur Marcel ruffau à Éric de
Barbieux au docteur Nicole Katheline
parce que on se rend compte
malheureusement que des élèves qui
peuvent subir le harcèlement finissent
sans parfois même se rendre compte par
élever leur seuil de tolérance et
accepter des choses qui ne peuvent pas
être acceptées pour se protéger eux-même
ce questionnaire il va permettre
probablement de libérer encore davantage
la parole il va nous permettre aussi à
nous de bénéficier de données
actualisées au niveau national les
dernières données dont nous disposons
sur le harcèlement datent de 2011 TikTok
snap chat n'existait pas à l'époque donc
c'est une journée très importante et
j'invite évidemment les parlementaires à
se mobiliser aussi mais nous allons
continuer à aller plus loin vous l'avez
dit développement de temps dédiés à
l'apprentissage de l'autre de la
différence de la tolérance de la
bienveillance dans toutes nos écoles
primaires dès la rentrée de septembre
prochain et dans une école par
département à partir de janvier et enfin
pour les parents en janvier 2024 un
module numérique pour les accompagné
dans le repérage des signaux faibles du
harcèlement à la maison c'était aussi
une demande très forte de leur part vous
le voyez premierre ministre a présenté
un plan il y a une mobilisation
collective et on continue à avancer je
vous remercie mer merci beaucoup